Fox for the longest time has been known
as you know Rupert Murdoch he just
stepped away he gave it to his son and
you know he was in the space for 60
years they had Roger Ells they produced
a lot of players over the years and they
were known as the enemy to the left they
were known as the enemy you know Fox is
uh against uh American values you were
on Pierce Morgan the interview that he
did a couple months ago could have been
even less than that and you said you
know Fox News is now protecting the
globalist agenda when did you see as
somebody that's been in the space them
making that transition of just being
some an organization that we could go to
for conservative eyeballs to all of a
sudden becoming a support of the
globalist agenda well that's my opinion
first of all I I think that um oh I see
them as they're pushing away from
America First Trump anybody but Trump
that's my opinion it looks like they've
gone toward the globalist agenda